today's video is kindly sponsored by
raid shadow legends
find out more later in the video hey 42
here
have you ever had one of those days
where it seems like the whole world is
plussing against you
your alarm fails to well alarm you
your mustache refuses to be tamed
your train's delayed and you arrive at
work late
flustered and disheveled only to find
your boss has decided
to channel gordon ramsay for the day
that
feeling of complete helplessness when
things fall apart
is fairly common we've all experienced
it from time to time
even when if we're being completely
honest with ourselves
we weren't entirely blameless it's so
common in fact that psychologists have a
term for it
self-serving bias as we know raid
shadow legends has a whole world of
amazing looking champions
all from their own unique faction and
those factions
have a lot of law here's a quick dive
into the first faction you meet
the banner lords remember you can use my
links below to download raid yourself
to your mobile phone or pc
so the banner lords are basically
medieval knights with a massive kingdom
in the west of talaria they're arrogant
and warlike and believe themselves to be
on the side of good
the lands of the banner lords were taken
from the non-humans by force
now with the bannerlords weakened by
wars of their king
the time may be at hand for these races
to write an
ancient wrong by whatever means
necessary
but it won't be easy not with the banner
lords having some amazing champions on
their side
such as baron and lord chamford i've
been playing raid for a while now and my
favorite thing is the campaign mode
with constant quest updates and a huge
variety of locations there's always a
new and exciting challenge
just around the corner so what's new in
raid this month
first up they've released 11 amazing new
champions
they've also released almost 200 brand
new missions to complete with an
exclusive legendary champion as your
reward
if you manage to finish them all so what
are you waiting for
go to the video description click on my
links
and support my channel by downloading
raid
today once you're in you can find me
in-game
under the name 42 and if you're fast you
can even join my clan
good luck and i'll see you in game
thanks to
our self-serving biases we have a
tendency to blame
our failures on external factors like
inconvenient weather or sod's law
whilst attributing good outcomes to
internal factors
such as our unparalleled ambition innate
brilliance
or disarming charm when it comes to
judging the behavior of
other people however we tend to be a
little more
well judgey we underestimate the
influence of external factors
and overestimates the importance of
internal motives
and dispositions psychologists have a
snazzy term for this
too fundamental attribution error
but if we aren't too careful a
combination of these two phenomena can
create a perceived
division between good people like us who
only do bad things because of
external factors and bad people like
them
who do bad things because they're
inherently flawed
one person who set out to demonstrate
that this is rarely the case
and that any of us can do bad things if
placed in the right situation
is psychology professor philip zimbardo
to do that he conducted what has since
become viewed as one of the most
infamous
and controversial social psychology
experiments
in history the results of which might
just
make you question what kind of horrors
you might be capable of
given the right set of circumstances
on the morning of the 15th of august
a police car worked its way through the
streets of stanford california
picking up college students as part of a
mass arrest
each student was charged read his rights
spread eagled across the police car
searched
and promptly driven to the local station
after they were formally booked they
were each blindfolded
and taken to the basement of the
psychology department
at stanford university not that anyone
familiar with this particular basement
would have recognized it at this point
because it had been given
one hell of a makeover the main corridor
had been boarded up at each end
and the labs had been transformed into
sparse cells
the corridor had no windows and all of
the clocks had been removed
making it impossible for anyone inside
to judge the time the reason for all
these odd renovations
was simple zimbardo and his team of
researchers
had transformed the basement into a
fully
functional prison surprisingly this
wasn't some kind of
extreme hazing ritual it was to set up
for
an ambitious social experiment to study
the psychological effects of prison life
the recently arrested students had
volunteered to take part
and all of them had undergone a series
of interviews and
tests to ensure they were intelligent
and of sound
mind without any psychological problems
medical disabilities or criminal records
despite the drama of their arrests it's
hard to imagine the young men were
particularly nervous about what lay
ahead of them during the experiment
this was stanford university after all
one of the top academic institutions in
the world
what could possibly go wrong
well they were about to find out
[Music]
it's safe to assume the first few
butterflies began to make themselves
known in the students bellies
pretty much as soon as they arrived in
prison
each of them was stripped naked
disinfected
de-loused and made to wear a dress-like
prison schmuck
labelled only with a prison id number a
heavy bolted
chain was placed on each of the
participants right ankles
and a nylon stocking was used to cover
their hair
from that point on they were only
allowed to address their fellow
prisoners
and refer to themselves by their prison
numbers
all of this might seem a little extreme
for a university approved psychology
experiment
but the setup was carefully orchestrated
to recreate the feelings of
humiliation emasculation and
anonymity often described by people
who've been in
actual prisons after all if the
experience didn't feel
real the results would have been
worthless
once settled in the prisoners were
finally introduced to their
guards who were in fact nine other
students who'd volunteered for the same
study
the guards all wore the same khaki
uniform complete with a club
whistle and sunglasses to promote a
sense of anonymity
and ensure the prisoners respected their
affarita
their instructions were simple they were
to do whatever they thought was
necessary
to maintain order and command respect
within the prison to say the prison
guards
embraced their roles would be an
understatement
on that first night they woke their
prisoners up
at ungodly hours for several counts
you know just to make sure there hadn't
been any escapes
and anyone who refused to participate
was punished with
mandatory push-ups understandably the
prisoners woke up the following morning
feeling a tad grumpy and they quickly
staged a rebellion
removing their stocking caps tearing off
their prison id numbers
and barricading themselves inside their
cells now
so far you may be thinking this all
sounds like a bunch of students
messing around and getting into
character
and perhaps that was the case to begin
with
but at some point relatively early on
something changed and the lines between
the reality of the experiment and the
fiction of the prison
began to blur when that happened what
had started out as an interesting social
experiment
rapidly spun out of control that first
morning the guards crushed the fledgling
rebellion
by spraying the prisoners with fire
extinguishers
and bursting into their cells the
prisoners were physically subdued and
split into two groups
the teachers pets who'd been the least
involved in the rebellion
and the ring leaders who'd led them into
battle
the guards removed the ringed leaders
beds from their cells
stripped them but naked and placed them
in solitary confinement
where their food and access to basic
human needs
like a functioning toilet was limited
meanwhile the class favorites were
placed in a different cell
and given a bunch of privileges
including toiletries
and access to better food though they
were only allowed to eat
if they did so in front of the other
prisoners
as you can imagine these tactics caused
resentment between the prisoners
and broke any feelings of solidarity
and the guards fans the flames of that
conflict
by swapping the two groups around for no
apparent reason
as tensions continued to rise one of the
prisoners
number 8612 began to show
signs of trauma alternating between fits
of
uncontrollable crying and bouts of rage
if the experiment had already dipped its
toes into
an ethical grey area by this point
this is where it dove in head first
instead of getting the distressed
participant the hell out of there
as you might expect from responsible
researchers
conducting a social psychology
experiment
zimbardo and his team had become so used
to thinking like prison authorities
they assumed prisoner 8612 was
attempting to fool them
so instead of releasing him the team
chastised him for being weak
and attempted to bribe him into becoming
an informant
unsurprisingly none of this went down
particularly well
with the possibly mentally disturbed
prisoner 8612
when he was promptly sent back to his
cell and his fellow inmates learned what
had happened
they quickly concluded that they weren't
allowed to leave the
so-called experiment under any
circumstances
they had become in effect genuine
prisoners
over the next few days things descended
into utter chaos
the guards became increasingly cruel and
tyrannical
forcing the prisoners to clean out
toilet bowls with their bare hands
increasing the number of push-ups during
counts and
even escalating their abuses described
afterwards
as becoming increasingly pornographic
in the middle of the night when they
thought they weren't being watched by
the researchers
the prisoners meanwhile grew more
submissive
disorientated and dejected
almost a week into the experiment
stanford phd student
christina maslak paid the research team
a visit
and was appalled at the way the
prisoners
the students so far as she was concerned
were being treated and it seemed her
outrage finally brought
the research team back to their senses
and reality
because six days after the experiments
begun it was abandoned
and all the students were released
weirdly enough it seems christina maslak
wasn't too rippled by what she'd
stumbled upon in the basement of the
stanford university psychology
department
because she went on to marry zimbardo
the following year
there's nothing quite like the sustained
mental and physical abuse of a group of
students
to bring two people together today
almost exactly 50 years on the stanford
prison experiment
serves as a cautionary tale an
unsettling indication of
what can happen to any of us if we
underestimate the influence of social
roles
and external pressures on our own
behavior
remember all of the participants in the
experiment were tested beforehand
and every single one of them was found
to be well adjusted
and intelligent just like you
zimbardo believed his experiment showed
flaws in the way we view the causes of
violent
or anti-social behavior traditional
psychology attempts to trace it to
early routes nestled within an
individual psyche
things like unresolved infantile
conflict or
defective genes but this doesn't account
for the fact that violent outcomes can
be generated by very different types of
people
including those who to all intents and
purposes
appear completely normal more than 40
years after the experiment took place
shocking photographs were released
showing american soldiers carrying out
horrific abuses of detainees at abu
ghraib prison
during the iraq war george bush declared
the war crimes had been the work of
a few bad apples but for zimbardo
if society puts good apples into a bad
barrel
the barrel rots them to see society's
violent individuals as nothing more than
bad apples is to make a large-scale
fundamental attribution error
where we underestimate the influence of
external systems
whether that be professional bodies
schools or
correctional facilities on our ability
to act
cruelly the stanford prison experiment
has attracted a lot of attention over
the decades
as much for its controversial methods as
for its
unsettling conclusions it's been the
subject of numerous films
and even inspired an episode of american
dad
but it's also been heavily criticized
not least because it has subsequently
come to light
that zimbardo himself instructed the
guards to ramp up the cruelty
which is probably why similar
experiments since have never been able
to quite replicate his results
the scientific rigor or utter lack
thereof
of the stanford prison experiment has
also been questioned
and the small sample of students wasn't
diverse enough to have any real
significance for society at large anyway
and that's not even touching on the very
long list of ethical concerns
the fact that the experiment continued
even after participants said they wanted
to leave
and the real risk of the participants
suffering long-term psychological harm
as a result of their treatment the fact
that zimbardo's famous experiment
was a bit of a shambles and doesn't
really hold up to modern scrutiny
might sound reassuring at first but it
probably shouldn't
after all whether the guards in the
experiment were cajoled into carrying
out their abuses
or dreamt them up all by themselves
nobody is calling into question whether
or not they actually
inflicted them on their inmates and
if the real conclusion of the stanford
prison experiment
is that normal people will do terrible
things
so long as someone with authority tells
them to
zimbardo in this case that doesn't
really sound
any more encouraging to me thanks for
watching